so just just the start I'm curious how
many people here actually own
cryptocurrency raise your hand and how
many of you store it on a hardware
wallet so we're very sorry to everyone
who who has their their hand up okay so
it's not just me it's me Josh and Thomas
so we're all hardware people we do
low-level hardware stuff in varying
degrees and we got into cryptocurrency
and so I can recommend to everyone
sitting in this room if you're a
security person there's not a lot of
people doing security and cryptocurrency
as much as that's painful to hear so
yeah I mean a lot of this is based on
reverse engineering
we love cryptocurrency I mean for us
crypto also stands for cryptography not
just cryptocurrency but no offense to
anyone with this talk it's just
something that it's a category that we
looked at and so the results kind of
speak for themselves and again this
wouldn't be possible alone so we have a
lot of people to think I'm not gonna go
through all of them individually just be
known that we're thankful to everyone on
this on this slide so yeah so we started
this about six months ago so we wanted
to take a look at cryptocurrency because
we own some cryptocurrency ourselves and
we saw that everyone's using
cryptocurrency wallets it's more and
more the thing that you do so we started
a group chat as you do nowadays and we
have 50,000 messages now and 1,100
images and I had my first I had my son
in the meantime as well so it's a really
long time that we spent looking at this
etc okay so what do we want to achieve
though because people don't give the
kinds of attacks so you can actually
perform against a cryptocurrency Wald
sin of credit so first attack is supply
chain attacks where you are able to
manipulate the devices before they get
to the end customer for more
vulnerabilities where you find a
vulnerability in the firmware and can
somehow either in fact reduce something
something else with the device side
channel attacks of course I think that's
one of the more obvious ones that people
are familiar with and also chip level
vulnerability so we were able to find
one
of each of these and so that's the talk
that we're gonna talk about each one of
these individually so but first what's a
what's a wallet just in case you are not
100% familiar with them so a wallet and
in general cryptocurrency how do you do
this
it's just asymmetric cryptography so you
have a private key and a public key the
public key basically it gives you the
address you can derive the address from
this the address is nothing other than
the public key of the wallet and you
have the private key and you need this
to send transactions so to actually
operate with the cryptocurrency so this
the private key is what needs to be kept
secret the public key is something that
everyone can know so that they can send
cryptocurrency to you but it kind of
sucks to have separate for each
cryptocurrency pair or for each wallet
maybe you want multiple wallets it sucks
to generate a new new new cryptographic
pair for each one of them so the people
the wonderful people behind Bitcoin have
thought of something for this and it's
called BIP 32-bit 44 and so what it is
is you have a cryptographic seed and you
can actually derive the the accounts
from from a single seed so you basically
store one seed and you're able to
implement and do unlimited amount of
wallets okay so basically you do key
derivation you add some data do key
derivation and you can have an unlimited
amount of wall it's while storing a
single seed and this is what you're
using when you're using a hardware
wallet so and of course for each key
derivation there will be a new private
key and a public key but it'll be
generated in a predictable manner and
you only need to store one secret seed
so you only have to store the seed you
can write it down and that's the
advantage but it's difficult to write
down because it's binary data so come
bit 39 which is what you're most used to
which is a format in which you can take
that cryptographic seed that binary data
and actually convert it to a set of
dictionary words that you can then
easily write down on a piece of paper
and store it at your mother's house or
store half of it at your mother's house
and half of it at your grandmother's
house and that way somebody would have
to go into both houses simultaneously to
get your words so yeah so what's a
hardware wallet so we just talked about
what's a wallet so why do you even need
a hardware wallet
the problem is of course computers can
get backdoored have malware running on
them and this is what you want to
prevent against how do you do this you
have a security device you store your
seeds externally usually this is a USB
connected device that you store your
your crypto on and so you can trust this
even if you can't trust your computer is
the idea so what happens is the computer
sends the transaction to the device the
device gets the transaction it can
actually confirm or deny the transaction
it also displays the transaction so
before you do any cryptographic signing
you can see is that actually what I was
doing or was my computer owned and is it
initiating the transaction for me so you
sign the transaction and yet also yeah
the seed never leaves the transaction
but the hardware science a transaction
for you you send it back to the computer
and the computer can actually take that
and send it to the Internet
okay so that's the quick rundown of how
crypto or sorry how Hardware wallets
work so the first thing that we looked
at was supply chain attacks which is
where Josh is gonna pick up you have a
Mike leave you with as we go through the
supply chain attacks our stickers are
for laptops they're not for security so
we're gonna be talking about the
stickers today they're there for laptop
decorations they're nefra security
supply chain tags are easy to perform
but they're quite hard to perform at
scale and the last takeaway that I hope
you leave you with is that the vendors
threat model may not actually be your
threat model so security stickers so
some of the wallet vendors are using
them I have seen them on other products
they seem to be quite popular I have a
friend and colleague named Joe
Fitzpatrick he also likes stickers so
the stickers that he makes are the same
as you would find on a security product
they have holo
they have unique serial numbers and they
can leave you with that nice warm fuzzy
security feeling and so Joe makes some
funny ones and can get a fits 140 Dutch
to approve stickers you don't have to
pay all the money for the FIPS one just
get the fits one
so the first device that I looked at was
the Tresor one and so the treasure one
actually has two levels of protection on
the packaging
there's the hologram sticker then the
actual box is enclosed with a with an
adhesive so it's supposed to be that you
actually have to rip open the box to get
into it but if you use a hot-air gun or
a hairdryer it's actually quite easy to
remove and so if you see on the left
there that's the original package and on
the right this is a box that I opened
and put everything back into and if you
look closely there is a little bit of
gap there the sticker has a little bit
of break but this was a first try and
it's pretty close so trust me taking a
sticker off is not very hard now if you
remember this picture the sticker is
we're going to come back to it so but
for the vendor this is actually a real
problem so treasure did put a blog post
out that one of the challenges they face
is that they're facing counterfeiting of
their devices so this is from their blog
post they say hey you know we've noticed
that there's counterfeit devices you
have to look at the stickers to see that
they're legit so I said remember a look
at that sticker so I bought that case I
bought a year and a half ago for my
previous stuff con talk and it's the
same sticker that they're saying is fake
here so I've been on their wiki it's
very confusing because there's three
sets of stickers so basically yeah
stickers are very confusing they cause
problems for end users and I was not
even sure if I bought a real transer
right clone one so this morning I got
out a new case and just to make sure I
took off the sticker using very
sophisticated of equipment including a
very expensive Dyson hairdryer that was
included in the Airbnb and I was able to
remove the sticker so it comes off
without any zero resid with zero residue
so yes
stickers do not provide any security on
the treasure T they switched it from the
box
the box can be open easily but now
there's a sticker on the USBC port again
as you would expect you use hot air and
you can easily remove it protip don't
set the hot air rework that high I had a
set for lead-free reworking and I
actually melted the enclosure so if
you're going to do this kind of supply
chain attack maybe you know set the key
a little lower but if you just Google
how to remove stickers the same attack
methods work so so this causes a bit of
confusion because the ledger device has
a very I will say in-your-face piece of
paper when you open the box that says
there are no stickers in this box
however I combed through about 250
one-star amazon reviews and a lot of
them have to do with confusion about the
stickers so some of them are actually
quite funny so this is was this one
started out note to wall adapter so I
was really into this so it's like okay I
pro tip what's this guy have to say and
basically he was complaining that
there's fingerprints on the device so
that's how he knew that was hacked
another one complained that the
fingerprints were on the wall end was a
hair underneath so if you're doing
supply chain attacks be sure to remove
any evidence of via fingerprints or her
hair so anyway stickers don't work
that's all I want to say about that once
you get through this enclosure though
you then have to have the challenge of
actually opening the enclosure these are
three different wallet devices Leger
Nano on the left the treasurer one and
the treasurer T on the bottom all of
which actually opened pretty easily so
the treasurer one even so this I'm still
not sure if that's the counterfeit or
the real one but I get on the on the
real one today I was able to pop open
the enclosure so it is ultrasonically
welded but you can pry it in there and
open it the ledger nano opens very
easily like without any equipment but
once you do this you know what do you do
once it's opened so the attack basically
is you take the microcontroller and you
rework it so you've removed the
microcontroller from the printed circuit
board and you put on a new one that you
bought from a distributor once you've
done that on the treasurer devices you
can
put your compromised bootloader on there
so this is I did not go as far to make
the compromised bootloader but I did
confirm that once I switched the
microcontroller I can connect with a
debugger over a swd and I have free
access to the chip so some of the parts
got blown off when I was we working but
the STM runs fine so yeah so you just
rework reflash and then you put
everything back together so next i want
to talk about Hardware implants so well
you may remember the story that came out
there was this big fight Bloomberg about
Hardware implants I want to make a
hardware implant I also wanted to have a
little bit of fun with this so we are in
honor of the Bloomberg story we just
have some you may have some issues with
it I were about to talk about the
Bloomberg allure which is a Super Micro
fun impact so the goals for this implant
is I wanted this in plan to happen after
receipt so it's both a supply chain
attack and a physical one like a red
team can perform this malicious insider
could also perform this attack zero
forward because more fun it has to fit
inside of a hardware wallet so it has to
be small it has to also bypass a core
security function otherwise it's not in
the plan very few components I what I
have a thousand of them with me so I
wanted to be able to for the makers and
the DIY RS that participate in the
hardware implant fund so what kind of
implant that I ended up with well I
decided to do it basically an RF
triggered switch and so the idea is on
these devices there's a button and the
button is the last line of defense so
all the vendors assume that the host is
going to be compromised they just assume
that's going to be easy because that's
software and so once you have a
compromised host you have to send it to
the device and then the human so humans
are still needed
humans have to look at it and say is
this the right transaction or not they
have to say yes or no
so now with this implant I can through
RF I can trigger the yes button so a
human is not required to send
transactions I can remotely trigger it
basically the RF comes in through the
antenna it goes through a single
transistor which is the main component
and it pulls the button low and I'm
sorry to say that the bill materials is
quite expensive at three
dollars and sixteen cents two dollars
and 61 cents of that is this
potentiometer I had to use so it's a
little bit expensive I'm sorry
also why is this so big I mean this is
an American time I can fit you on them
what's the deal why is it so big
well I opt amaizing it for him this
anyway so it would be more fun to use
but basically put the antenna in and
then there's an out button and like I
said every thousand with me
so just for scale this is how it fits on
the electric nano this is how it fits on
the Tresser it is also because
breadboard friendly is a thing so we
made it breadboard friendly so you can
also play along very easily underneath
so then the last challenge with an RF
implant is how do you design an antenna
to fit in there and so the big thing
there with an SMA connector is the first
prototype I did experimented with a few
antenna designs but the remember it all
has to fit inside the ledger so that's
actually quite easy because the ledger
Nano has plenty of room to insert extra
circuitry and so it quite fits easily in
the legend animal and then so I did the
implant and then I started to go through
the wallet process I got to his check
that said is my you know is the ledger
device genuine and here I actually got a
little bit nervous because it wasn't
working and so it wasn't working and I
was like how maybe that maybe they're
checking this you know how how did they
detect it don't worry it was only Linux
so it just doesn't work on Linux so that
was no problem I did it this on Windows
and no problems device is genuine I was
able to move on so the thing is this is
a very crude receiver but the attacker
can always use more power so here I have
this is my antenna setup in the basement
and with a 50 watt transmitter I could
remotely trigger the button at 11 meters
and at this point I'm just limited by my
basement size I'm pretty I'm very
confident that I'd be able to remotely
trigger this thing further yeah so here
we're going to see a demo of what it
looks like and so the other problem you
have with Hardware implants is how do
you know you have the implanted device
so you have to label it some way ledger
has this kind of Latin phrase that
Scrolls
I wanted
my own lamb fries and so this is how I
know this is my implanted device so what
we're going to see is that the
transaction screen is going to show up
this is and I'm basically gonna trigger
this remotely so I'm going to show the
radio come in and then it's going to
approve the transaction without any
hands so this is the transaction there
is the screen going this is the way
you're supposed to verify there's the
radio coming at 433 megahertz and then
it's going to proceed to the next screen
without me touching the button there you
go so this is remotely triggered and
that would have sent a transaction so if
you think about the context that you
have a malicious software implant that
sent it to a wrong address the attacker
now can remotely accept that and bypass
the security model
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah on the recaps securities are
first stickers are for laptops not for
security supply chain tacks are very
easy to do at a hardware level but
they're quite harder to do at scale and
when the vendor says that the device is
genuine that may mean different things
so that's something that I found kind of
funny and it's almost correct if you put
funny constants in your code they will
end up on defcon slides and they won't
be laughing with you small mistake they
won't end up at DEFCON there will be at
CCC and so introducing the food pipe
vulnerability it's a bootloader
vulnerability and the legend on OS we
did not come up with this constant it's
literally in the code as well see later
so the name was not ours but we liked it
so we also bought the domain food baby
the lettering on OS is a very simple
wallet it simply has a small display it
has a USB port and two buttons that's
really authors and if you take it apart
you see it's just some pieces of plastic
the display and the PCB and looking at
the PCB it kind of has an interesting
architecture where you have an esteemed
32 which is just a general-purpose
microcontroller and an ste 31 which is a
secure element that is for example used
in pay TV and so on and it's regarded as
a very high-security chip basically and
if you turn the PCB around you see that
they were nice enough to leave the
programming port for the stm32 open to
us enabled
and this has been suspected by other
people we verified it but you know you
have to go through it and obviously
ledger is aware of this and so let's
look at the security model that the
legend on OSS the basic idea is that if
we look at this device we we kind of
have this schematic of the stm32 being
on the left and the SC 31 on the right
and as you can see all peripherals are
connected to the stm32 that is because
the st 31 does not have enough pins to
connect peripherals it literally only
has a one pin interface which is for the
smart card protocols basically and so
all the heavy lifting is done by the
stm32 and letter splits this up into the
unsecured part and the secure part and
the idea is that the stm32 acts as a
proxy so it's basically the hardware
driver for the button for the display
for the USB similar to a North Bridge in
your standard computer and when you take
a computer and want to make a
transaction you create your transaction
on the computer it goes through USB to
the stm32 and the stm32 you then
forwards it to the St 31 the St 31 then
says oh a new transaction I want to ask
the user to confirm it so it sends a
display command to the stm32 which in
turn displays it on the screen and then
you press the yes button again it goes
the same route to the St 31 which then
internally signs the transaction so the
seat never leaves the device and our
sign transaction goes back through the
STM through USB to the computer to us
this means if this chip is compromised
we can send malicious transactions to
the SD 31 and confirm them ourselves or
we can even go and show a different
transaction on the screen then we're
actually sending to the SD 31 and letter
is aware of this and we'll talk about
how they try to mitigate this later but
first we have to find an exploit because
while we do have debugging access to the
chip
hardware access is sometimes kind of
buggy no offense so we we wanted to have
a software bug and so we started reverse
engineering the firmware upgrade process
and when you look at the at the
bootloader the bootloader for the latter
used to be open-source and back then
they didn't have any verification of the
firmware so if you you could basically
boot the device into bootloader mode
flash whatever from where you want and
then it would run it after someone selim
in this case wrote about this they
changed it and they changed it to do
some cryptographic measure and we were
too lazy to reverse engineer that
cryptographic measure because it's very
time consuming very hard so we looked
more at the part surrounding it and how
we can maybe find a back in the
bootloader to break it and it turns out
then when you when you when you try to
opt
when you try to upgrade your letter U it
accepts four different commands one is
select segment which allows you to
select the address space at which your
firmware will be flashed one is the load
command which allows you to write data
to flash then you have the flash command
which is basically like F sync on Linux
and writes your changes to the
non-volatile memory and you have the
boot command which verifies the flash
the flash code and starts booting it so
to us the boot command is the most
interesting because it provides all the
verification and attempts to ensure that
no malicious images booted and it turns
out that if you issue the boot command
it compares the whole image to whatever
cryptographically function they use and
if it's successfully verified they write
a constant to the address 0 X 800 3000
and that constant is food babe and so to
not have to verify the entire flash on
each boot
they just do this once so only after
firmware upgrade
so basically if you boot up the ledger
it boots it weights 500 milliseconds it
checks if you have a button pressed if
yes it goes to bootloader
otherwise it Louis loads the constant at
0 X 800 3,000 and if it's food babe it
boots the firmware so our goal is to
write food babe to that at address first
attempt we just issue a select segment
command to exactly that address we just
write food paper to it flash and reset
the device didn't work unfortunately
so we had to do more reverse engineering
it turns out that they use an
interesting approach to ensure that you
don't accidentally flash over the
bootloader so they basically blacklist a
whole memory region so if you try to
flash from 0 X 800 for x 0 up to 0 X 800
3000 it returns an error if you try to
directly write to food babe they thought
about it and they have a very specific
code path to prevent that so they mem
set it to 0 and you're screwed again and
then finally it writes assuming you
didn't error out but it turns out that
the stm32 has kind of an interesting
memory map and on a lot of chips you can
not only map your flash to one address
but you can also have it mapped to
another address and in this case the
flash is indeed also mapped to the
address 0 and so the bootloader uses a
blacklisting approach so it only
excludes certain memory areas but it
doesn't use whitelisting where you could
only explicitly write to this memory
region so they do not like writing to 0
X 0 profit second attempt we just select
the segment at 3000 which maps to 0 X
800 3000 we right foot babe to it we
flush reset
and we can flush custom firmware awesome
so
what do you do when you have a device
that where the display is not big enough
to run doom with a custom firmware so in
this case it's an original letter press
the button put it into bootloader mode
which is part of the normal operation
and
if you want to play a bit of snake come
by later so how are they protecting
against this I've mentioned before Leger
is aware that you can reflash this stm32
and they are they put in some measures
to prevent you and doing malicious stuff
and basically what they do and this is
very simplified and we did not bother to
fully reverse-engineered because we
didn't need to basically when when the
chip boots it sends its entire firmware
to the ste 31 which then performs some
kind of hashing also verifies that the
firmware is authentic and it also
measures the time it takes it to Center
firmware this is to prevent you from
just running a compression algorithm on
the stm32 and send it very slowly how do
we bypass this so our idea was because
we don't only have flash we also have
runs so what if we create a compromised
and compressed firmware that copies
itself to ram we jump to it and then it
writes its entire compressed firmware to
flash and compress in that case and then
we just call the original code on the
seeker element it will verify the
firmware it will run with a real timing
and boots irregularly and so we
attempted this it took quite a quite a
while to achieve because basically you
can't do zip you can't do lzma because
even if you compress the image you don't
have enough space for complex compressor
so you our attempt was to find duplicate
bytes squeeze them together and make
space for our custom payload and
basically we just have a table that says
ok now you will have six zeros or
something and our each table entry only
takes a single byte so and it's only
like 10 instructions in a sampler to run
this decompress cells so you don't have
the large code base it's very easy to
use and it turns out that even with a
very simple detector like in this case
we rerun the script to find the longest
stuff liket data that you can see on the
first try we get like 260 bytes of space
for our payload which is enough for a
lot of things let's say and we have a
working proof of concept of this and we
would go into a lot of details but if we
we only got an hour and so we will
release after this talk and
non-offensive an example of this that
you can look at how does it work what
can you do even if you're from where is
attempting to be verified and we also
and this is very exciting we are working
with youtuber Life overflow and he
created a 20 minute video on walking
through this entire food pipe
vulnerability how the verification works
and how to bypass it to a certain degree
we don't want to weaponize it so we did
not we will not release the first there
the full thing but yeah very excited for
this stay tuned on our Twitter and we'll
link it for sure as part of this we also
have a lot of software that we will
release so public release will release
the snake firmware so hopefully this
evening you'll be able to play snake on
your letter if you bought with some
Bitcoin at 20,000 an hour bankrupt you
can at least play snake we will open
source the compressor and the extractor
we build a logic analyzer plugin for the
smart cut protocol and we build software
that analyzes the communication between
the stm32 and the SD 31 on the ledger
specific data and you can just dump it
so if you guys are interested in for
example trying to break into the SD 31
please have a go and letter has a second
device which is called the letter blue
we assume the reason it's called the
letter blue is because it contains
bluetooth but they never enabled
bluetooth so it's basically just a
regular letter with a color display and
a big battery in it and we call this
part fantastic signals and how to find
them
because when we open up this device and
we were chatting we have this nice
telegram chat room where we are chatting
24/7 while doing this and we open up the
device and the first thing like
literally five minutes after opening it
I saw that you have the secure element
on the left and the stm32 on the right
you have some other stuff like the
Bluetooth module and so on the trace
between the secure element and the
microcontroller is pretty long and
contains a pretty fast signal so what is
the long conductor with a fast changing
current anyone got a clue correct it's
an antenna so I pulled out my hack RF
software-defined radio this is just a
very more sophisticated RTL SDR so you
can just sniff arbitrary signals with it
I got a random city telescope antenna on
Amazon and I have my ledger blue and so
on this screen you can see the blue
thing is the radio spectrum around 169
megahertz and if we start entering our
pin we can see that there's a weak
signal
you guys see where this is going on the
on the radio unfortunately that signal
is pretty weak luckily they included in
antenna okay they call it USB cable but
I'm not so sure about it so this time
with USB connected and we do the same
thing again you can see like crazy radio
spikes and this is right next to each
other but even if you go a couple of
meters so I was limited as Josh by my
living room space you get a couple of
meters of decent reception so our goal
was to find out what is this signal and
if we just look at the recorded
amplitude of the signal we get this and
if you do a lot of probing and so on you
immediately see okay there are spikes
and there are 11 of them and then
there's a pause and then there's more
spikes so this is probably some kind of
protocol that first sends 11 bytes of
data then pauses and then sends more
data so we looked at the back of the
device started probing every single
connection and try to figure out is this
the secure element is this whatever and
it turned out to be the display bus so
we can sniff information on what is sent
to the display remotely and if you if we
look at the signal that gets sent in
blue is the signal that gets sent when
you press the letter 0 on the pin pad
and an orange when you press the letter
7 so we can see a very clear difference
at certain points on the signal which
confirmed our suspicions but building
software for this is kind of boring like
digital signal processing is not really
my thing so what do we do and we wanted
to increase the password load in our
talk a bit and so we are hacking
blockchain IOT devices using artificial
intelligence
in the clouds
so our idea was rerecord training
signals we use some kind of pre
filtering we train an AI on it profit
literally problem is getting training
data really sucks because you don't want
to sit there for 10 hours pressing the
same key on a pin pad it really doesn't
sound like fun and so this needs
automation so we took an Arduino we took
a roll of masking tape a piece of
acrylic glass a piece of advice and this
is a who have a pen for the extra amount
of Chinese back door and we let this run
for a couple of hours and you can
actually see that every time it presses
down you can see that the digit that you
pressed is highlighted and the
difference in the signal we saw earlier
is probably the x and y-coordinate of
where it highlights the button and
that's the difference we can see in the
train and in the in the in the trace and
so we had a lot of recorded data now we
create a training set we created a test
set pre-processing tens of low AI model
it's really easy surprisingly and we
tried our test set did a prediction and
so the big question how accurate is it
and it turns out so this is the the
result of a cut of the test set and if
we zoom in on this this basically tells
you we have the the signal this gray
thing is just a picture representation
of the signal and it tells you how sure
it is what digit is in this case it's
seven with ninety-eight percent
likelihood so pretty good in our test
set we only have one wrong result
and overall we get around ninety percent
accuracy and to move this in the cloud
we are hosting this on the Google cloud
as the letter AI for you guys to play
with and we'll publish it online with a
limited data set that is trained on a
very closed space you cannot do
something super malicious with it but
it's nice to play around and see how
this was done and this brings us to the
next part glitch me if you can thank you
[Applause]
so now we're going to talk about the
silicon level vulnerability glitching
attacks fault injection so to review
we'll be talking about the treasure one
and so I just want to go over very
quickly what the architecture is of the
Tresor one and some previous work that
was done so the treasure one is a quite
a simple embedded device it consists of
only a few components it has a OLED
display and some buttons and has a USB
connector that are all externally facing
internally it's has its main brain if
you will as the stm32f4 controller which
controls all the other operations on the
treasure the display the USB and the two
buttons so last year we gave a talk at
DEFCON breaking Bitcoin hardware wallets
here we use the chip whisper to mainly
do the glitching attacks the conclusions
from last year is that the eff 205 was
vulnerable to fault injection but we it
was inconclusive if we could do a
exploit via the fault
so this year we have a different result
but the output of that work was this
board was called the breaking Bitcoin
board basically it was a treasure clone
that just made it easy to attach wires
and probes and so we made this board the
science Commandant's are all in mine
that's open source hardware now this is
the chip whisper setup that we were
using so we made the board specifically
to fit on the chip whisper target board
and this is just what it looks like when
used the chip whisper GUI to perform
MacLeish and here we were doing Apple
application level code so it was very
different but I even
and then I met it too between times yeah
so fortunately we had Josh to do the
talk last year and to kind of exhaust a
lot of the firmware vulnerabilities that
were actually hardware vulnerabilities
in the firmware that might have been
there so we immediately knew that we
could exclude this and so you can start
looking at the underlying
microcontroller so in this case it's the
stm32 microcontroller that they use
inside of it and it controls everything
so compromising to stm32 microcontroller
means that you can compromise you can
compromise the device so the I mean so
there's a couple of papers that have
covered some of the vulnerabilities in
the stm32 specifically there's one which
describes a UV attack which lets you
down grade the security on the stm32 so
we determined that paper unfortunately
does not apply to to our result because
the traceur is smart enough when it
boots to check the value stored in flash
and if it has been altered in any way to
set it correctly so they actually even
protect that against this kind of attack
but nevertheless you can see that there
are some vulnerabilities so there's
another paper which unfortunately has
not been published yet and we couldn't
get in touch with the authors yet that
should be coming out in January
hopefully which describes glitches
against the stm32 f1 and the stm32f4 the
f1 and they have three and so basically
here's the product matrix so three of
them are already vulnerable so but we're
looking at the stm32 f2 and potentially
the stm32f4 if we're talking about the
trays or model-t so those we do not have
vulnerabilities for yet so let's take a
look at how how it works really quickly
so the way that STM implements security
on the stm32 is that they store an
option bite and the option bite the
thing to remember is on on a cortex m3
or m4 microcontroller that you don't
have anything other than flash so even
though they call it option bite or refer
to this as fusing or being permanent and
hardware it's still stored and
flash just like the user application is
stored in flash so it's the same exact
same non-volatile memory that's
otherwise used so basically the when you
get a new stm32 it's shipped in state
where you have full access so that's how
Josh was able to rework a board and
flash up with new firmware and there's
the ultimate security is what's called
RDP 2 so there you have no access but
you can see that basically if you have a
value other than a or CC which
correspond to our DP 0 and our db2
respectfully then you have what's called
RDP 1 and this is interesting because it
doesn't give you access to the flash
which is actually where the
cryptographic seed is stored on the
traceur but it gives you access to ram
it gives you access to the registers but
it doesn't give you a flash access like
I said and it doesn't even give you
single stepping as well so connecting a
debugger in this mode will actually
cause the hardware to heartful which
we'll see in a second so basically what
we want to try to do is to downgrade our
DP 2 which is what the tresor is set to
and we want to be able to access the
device at our DP 1 which is somewhat
vulnerable state so this so i should say
that this is this is the correct way to
approach this and it's great for doing
an educational talk but in all honesty
there's three of us and so we did this
completely in the dark over up over
three months trying different parameters
on our on our glitch setups which I'll
show later and we're able to find this
but I'm here to explain it to all of you
so that it's easy to reproduce so if you
actually watch the stm32 f2 boot you'll
see that it's relatively slow and it's
only this slow after you power cycle the
board so it takes approximately 1.8
milliseconds to boot which is a
microcontroller terms pretty slow so you
can see there's the power supply there's
the eye open and that's approximately
how long it takes to boot the the
firmware so you can see that's where the
i/o actually toggles so 1.8 milliseconds
later so we just throw some firmware to
basically turn toggle one of the pins
measured it with an oscilloscope now we
have the timing of how long that takes
so that's not super interesting because
that's not
a trigger and each one of these
microcontrollers internally it has a
boot rum so it has some some ROM
read-only memory right it's not
non-volatile memory it's not the flash
it's literally a ROM which is inside the
chip itself it's it's hard coded it
cannot be fixed or patched that gets
executed first so we wanted to actually
attack that because anything else is the
user application and that's what Josh
said last year so you can kind of start
to fiddle this down so you see that one
point four milliseconds of the reboot
nothing actually happens because this is
now the reset line and so the reset line
goes high after one point four in
milliseconds so you can ignore the first
one point four in milliseconds after you
cycle the power so now the next step
that you can actually do is you can
connect what's called a shunt resistor
so in you you I mean so oscilloscopes
are there to measure voltage and so you
want to actually measure current to be
able to know how much power consumption
I mean how much power is being consumed
by device so you do what's called a
shunt measurement and that's what I have
on this slide right here so you have the
blue signal is now actually the power
consumption and so now you can actually
look and see what's happening so the
first thing that happens is we have the
execution of the boot ROM so you can see
the in the power consumption curve you
can clearly see this moment in time then
you have basically where the flash and
option bytes to actually get read
somewhat at least within the boot ROM
and finally the third distinctive moment
in time is where the application
actually begins to execute so now we've
taken this 1.8 milliseconds which is a
relatively long time and reduced it to
200 microseconds that we're actually
interested in and not only that the we
know that we're actually interested in
having slightly higher power consumption
than the normal execution of the
bootloader or of the boot ROM rather and
this is somewhere between let's say 170
microseconds and 200 microseconds so
this is the time at which we actually
need to glitch and this is also
reasonable parameters if you're trying
to reproduce this at home
so what do you need to reproduce this
thing so I the greatest thing that came
out in the last couple of years is the
these cheap Chinese power supplies where
you
take a cheap you know old wall wart from
one of your old Linksys routers you plug
it in and then you actually have a
controllable power supply with with
voltage and current and you can adjust
this and control this and so that's what
we're using here the second thing that I
have on the I mean the second thing that
I have to actually control the timing is
an FPGA I mean I use that PGA's for
everything and this is something that
was easiest to put together with an FPGA
because FPGAs have constant timing so
finally we have a multiplexer there as
well and the multiplexer is actually
switching between two voltages between
ground so completely cutting the voltage
off and the normal operating voltage of
the microcontroller and finally we have
a debugger the j-link which is highly
advised if you want to ever do JTAG
stuff so it's just a JTAG debugger and
basically what happens is you let this
run for a while and it looks like this
it's not really super super eventful so
you can see that that the voltage the
yellow signal is actually the voltage
and you can see we're just dipping the
voltage at different points in time and
simultaneously we have a Python script
checking if we have JTAG access or not
and some pro tip to all the new dads if
you do this at home you can turn your
oscilloscope towards the door so that
you when you get up at night because the
baby's crying you can see if it's still
running or not so it's it's very it's
highly advised so now Thomas is gonna
tell us how how to get the seed into
into RAM so we had this thing running
for three months roughly across three
continents because josh is in America
Dimitri is in Russia and I'm in Germany
and so it took us three months to get a
successful glitch and even then we
didn't believe it at first because we
exhausted everything basically and the
only reason we finally got it working is
that we did a mistake where we mistook
17 microseconds with 170 microseconds
and had it run for a longer time and
that's how we found out that the boot
rom is actually super slow to boot on
this device
but and so once we have this downgrade
from our db2 to our ep-1 we were able to
read the RAM but we cannot read the
flash which actually contains the the
seed and so how do we find this and our
idea was we start reviewing the upgrade
procedure because on the tress or the
way the bootloader works is it doesn't
require your PIN or anything to upgrade
the firmware which makes sense because
let's say you have a buck and the pin
function you want to somehow be able to
get rid of it right and the other thing
is if you flash a fully valid firmware
it retains the data it retains your seat
if you flash and non-genuine one it
actually will erase your seat and so on
and the big and they do a really good
job on the firmware verification we
reviewed it for days and days and days
and didn't find anything but so how does
this upgrade procedure work how is the
seat retained and so when you review the
the relevant code you see that there's a
call to back up metadata which sounds
like you're just going to retain somehow
your data and indeed you can see that
it's literally a mem copy from the data
on flash we're interested in into RAM
and so our basic procedure was we go
into a boot loader we started firmware
upgrade and we we stopped it before the
run gets cleared because if you finish
the upgrade procedure the treasurer
actually clears its memory again which
is a very decent way to do it but we
found a way to retain it and run so it
turns out that when you start the
firmware upgrade process
it eventually asks you to verify the
checksum of what you just flashed and it
turns out that at this point in time the
seed is still in RAM and we can read it
out
we are RDP to and this is relatively
simple simple to you once you actually
managed to glitch the device you
basically just run open OCD dump image
you get an image of the SRAM and you
have the whole Ram contents and so how
what are we gonna do Thomas what-what
high-tech hacking tool will we be using
today to extract the C so we actually
before we were successful we had hours
of talks on how do we how is this heat
stored and so on and we found this super
sophisticated seed extraction tool that
only runs on POSIX and POSIX like
systems
it's called strings right and so
basically it turns out then when you
have a firmware dump as we do if you
have a random as we do now and we go to
we just run strings on the dump we get a
couple of really nice words and I don't
know if you remember the intro but this
is your seat
and you might be wondering what what
this little number is this is your PIN
to the device that was a great day and
so Josh or one of Josh employees took
all this mess we created on our desks
and made it into this nice device which
is basically a socket where you put in
your chip and then we can read out the
seed and so on including the board
design the FPGA codes for the very
locker that we use I mean if somebody
wants to they can apply it and do the
same thing with one of the ice sticks or
one of the more open-source friendly
fpga boards this just happens to be the
one that we all had lying around and
could reproduce the work with you can go
ahead and do it I mean we suspect I
think Thomas said we suspect you might
be able to do with an Arduino as well
because the actual glitch pulse is only
approximately 60 microseconds or sorry 6
6 microseconds and in time so it's a
relatively slow signal as well so it
should be relatively repeatable even
with even with something cheaper than
this but this is a way to automate this
even better and to not have dangling
wires or any of the small soldering that
was required to do it in C dough in the
device which we had on the previous life
so all of that we're gonna have on
github and so I think the the final the
final thing what's one one more thing
before we are sorry one more thing so
this breaks a lot of the the treasure
security but there is a way to protect
your seat against this so if you use a
passphrase on your device the way we
understood it it basically doesn't allow
somebody with hardware access to steal
all your funds so if you add a
passphrase to your treasure a good
passphrase and your machine has not
already owned you can somehow you can
somewhat protect against this but a lot
of people don't so we are really sorry
we didn't mean any harm
so I mean yeah that's the conclusion I
would say so
so yeah I mean we so all this stuff
we're gonna put online I guess I said so
you can follow us for the links on the
online so wallet that fail it's a domain
name it believe it or not fail is a TLD
so you can go to github.com wallet that
failed twitter calm while it fail you
can follow me Thomas and Josh on Twitter
as well and like I said we'll be
releasing all this stuff so it will go
up slowly just cuz I think when we set
out six months ago we did not expect us
to have 100% success in everything that
we were planning to do so that's a first
for me
this saddest part is that we have more
vulnerabilities to other wallet to add
only one hour and so we also have some
stuff to give out so we have the
hardware implant PCBs we have a thousand
of them if you want to get some money
don't rush yeah we even have components
for them for like 100 devices so hit us
up and we can do something thank you
[Music]
amazing talk I feel really inspired to
break things apart in a very creative
way we have some time left for questions
so if you have questions please line up
at the microphones we're going to start
with a question from the internet yeah
so maybe let's start with bid fees so we
only talk about somewhat secure wallets
we didn't want to use the Chinese phone
in this talk so we love pretty hard and
we ordered some but yeah yeah and I mean
this was covered extensively so so
another guy who you should follow on
Twitter cyber Gibbons gave a talk at
hardware do on on the topic of the bid
fight he was summarizing research that
he did in conjunction with a bunch of
other people as well so if you're
interested in the bid file you should go
look at them so the second question was
about ARM based controllers I mean all
of these were arm based every single
chip as far as I know that we looked at
was was ARM based in one way or another
yeah and there's so if you're interested
in this look at glitching the Nintendo
switch where they glitch the Tegra used
in the Nintendo switch which is very
interesting and will give a lot of
inspiration in that regard basically
thank you a question for microphone four
please
do you first thank you for the issues as
soon as
and if anyone is interested in affecting
other words which you really interested
me through my Dorota cars cooperated and
we have a responsive of this virtual
program and you mentioned
we'll give solutions so let me give you
my like there's a resource and
convenience
[Music]
so maybe first off thank you one thing
we should mention is that when we looked
at the treasure code the reason we had
to end up glitching this ship for three
months is that we couldn't break the
firmware otherwise so they do a great
job and it's really awesome so I mean
yes the the firmware on the treasure is
is something to look at I mean I
recommend that I mean we all do
consulting work as well and so it's
something that I recommend that people
who are interested in looking at how to
prevent certain do mitigations and
hardware it's an excellent project to
look at and so treasure should be
commended on that but at the end of the
day it doesn't mean that the chip that
the treasurer uses is secure against
these kinds of attacks and that's where
we had a fallback to looking for silicon
vulnerabilities against against a chip
or sorry or wallet like the treasure
this is a very difficult problem
governments especially a physician can
do Geographic attestation both as I saw
were published and that the acquisition
can help verify otherwise
another question from microphone 3
actually I have a suggestion I rigged it
short though because usually we just
take questions one sentence a few MC us
actually have jtac connected the
hardware fuses yep so this might be used
to at least slow down which Inc attacks
I think I agree but these are not
cortex-m microcontrollers I can tell you
that with 100% certainty yeah it has the
new a lot with the fact that the the
microcontrollers that are being used in
these devices they're built to spec to
the spec that arms specified that arm
thinks would be a good set of features
for this class of device or rather for
the for the CPUs for the class of device
that they ended up getting put in so
anything cortex-m is gonna have boner
abilities that are more or less like the
silicon vulnerabilities that we have
it's just a I mean if you ask me I think
it's a matter of time just to sit there
I mean fortunately we had something like
three months of just glitching to be
able to find find these bugs but if you
can apply that much to find a silicon
attack you might be able to find this
kind of vulnerability as well in other
cortex-m products only if three minutes
oh good another question from microphone
for please
love these devices did you find that the
parameter was in any way obfuscated or
inverted so basically you on these chips
you cannot really encrypt it from where
I'm on the SD 31 you can encrypt it but
we didn't have to look at it because the
sts-31 is not something you have to
break but so no there was no real
obfuscation that we could see but we
also don't have the coat in the case of
letter so I just stared at Ida Pro for
hours and yeah
the next person the microphone for I
mean so we already covered how the
treasurer works so there is only one
chip and it's the stm32 so I know that
there was a known issue with treasure
back in the day where they weren't
seeding the basically the RNG correctly
but this was fixed but for our attacks
this wasn't this wasn't an issue I mean
if you were concerned about how strong
these are how strong the random number
generators are for creating a seed you
could actually create a bit 39 wallet
outside of of any one of these and then
just use them for their hardware
features and I mean get get the seed
from outside and if you have a question
do move to the microphone if you're able
to but first we have another question
from the internet no but if you send it
to us we are happy to look at it you
know sorry oh you did
[Music]
I mean maybe on that note I would say
that in terms of looking at the what
wallets are actually being used you'll
find that the I mean so the legend is of
a very popular wallet the Tresor is a
very popular wallet but since the Tresor
is open-source there's a lot of clothes
and forks of the Tresor and when I say
that not all of them run the latest
security patches that have been applied
to the Tresor code base so that's also
something that you can do is basically
diff the projects and see which one of
them which ones are staying up-to-date
in which art your question is to be the
very last one today to speak directly
into the microphone even closer to the
night seeing as this is the first CCC
for many of us and some of us might not
have making that much experience in
Hardware acting do you have any tips for
beginners yeah lots of them so by now do
we know you're learning what mistakes
you do with it and what learn learn how
hardware works basically watch a lot of
online videos and I think you gave
presentations you gave presentations I
gave some presentations so just watch
talks watch Life overflow life overflow
great great YouTube channel on exactly
this stuff and yeah and also don't
hesitate to reach out to us if you have
a question always contact us info and
wallet fail on Twitter wherever we are
happy to talk to you it might take a
while but yeah
[Music]
but I'll say I started with Arduino - I
mean I've anybody alright thank you guys
so much for the very nice question and
you guys for the amazing and inspiring
job thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]